After a long day waiting around at the airport
to not only go back home and hope for better luck the next day,
I was really tired and went home to take a nap.
Later that day
I started making dinner
with a few random ingredients I had in my home.
Got started making my lightly sweetened,
freshly milled eincorn zucchini bread butter,
and then moved on to the main course,
a coconut pot pie style chicken without the pie crust.
Before we had left to the airport,
I put a container
freshly shredded pasture and primary chicken in the freezer,
so this was a fast food meal that was ready to go.
To make things interesting, I added some onion, carrots,
herbs I grew in my garden last year,
coconut milk, a little flour, and salt and pepper.
While that simmered,
I squeezed the juice out of a freshly grated zucchini
and then let it sit to dry out a bit while we enjoyed dinner.
The final batter came together in minutes
with the addition of two backyard eggs for my chickens,
vanilla coconut oil,
and chopped walnuts, which unfortunately I didn't have time to sprout,
something I normally like to do.
Neutralized by the acid and enzyme inhibitors,
this zucchini bread came out more perfect than I had hoped,
with a crispy edge and that insanely undescribable
but completely doable zucchini bread taste.
Hoping our next flight goes out this bread is coming with.